I think that the most important
innovation development Italy right
what's that is like an impact the state
of the world in the coming decades is
the fact that it has an increasing
capacity in poorer countries to need to
come up with innovations and it's up to
now innovations have been done mainly in
rich countries and they have assumed a
rich country content because oh you have
a television changer which assumes you
have a radio television you have an
Internet solution that assumes you
already have broadband access or hand
the computer so the innovations in which
countries have trouble moving towards
poor countries because the context that
really assume is not there but as you
have more and more the capacity to
innovate in poor countries in China in
India in Latin America more and more
progress are being designed taking the
reality of a customer of those customers
think ultimately heart so for example
since the Middle Ages the banks were a
minute backs are round for 700 years a
thanks only service about thirty percent
of people only about thirty percent of
humans are in the banking system cell
phones are covering more or less over
seventy percent of the adult population
of the world well if we can tag on to
your cell phone things that are
currently being distributed resolve few
banking systems in countries that don't
have that penetration of a banking
system we will incorporate a lot of
people to climax will incorporate a ton
of people to access to medical knowledge
and they wouldn't otherwise have because
now we are connected and but the people
who are going to be thinking about those
innovations are going to keep coming up
with those ideas our people in poor
countries that have those poor in
citizens has their main concern as their
main goal and they're taking into
account the reality so innovation as
innovations
to a poor countries solutions are going
to be more adequate for the oh yes